by the time I graduated from Cornell and
age 18. I was very very disillusioned
with the universities
somehow
I had a conception of wisdom which was
something entirely different from the
professionalism I found at Cornell
University
and
I should mention that
when I graduated I was offered a
three-year Fellowship in the sage School
of philosophy at Cornell
so I could have gone on there for my PhD
in philosophy
and in part of fact I accepted this and
started out on a doctoral program in
philosophy
and if you can imagine
after three weeks
I was so disappointed
and felt so out of harmony with the
presiding Spirit there
that I went to the
head of the philosophy Department
and told him I have not yet touched any
any money
I am quitting
and he asked me what are you going to do
I said I'm going to the state of Oregon
to be a lumberjack
and it was on my way that after
communicating
this decision to my brother who was
studying chemical engineering at Purdue
my brother took my this letter to the
chairman of the physics department and
said I have this young brother is is
smart but he's a little crazy can you do
anything for him
and so the professor of the the head of
the physics department who happened to
come from Austria my country
he said tell your brother I want to see
him Monday morning in my office he is
he's a graduate assistant in our
department that's I'm offering him that
so you see my attempt to escape from the
universities did not succeed I had
scarcely
cut my bridges as I thought then against
my will if you wish I was called back so
I spent two years then at Cornell
University getting a master's degree in
physics
and I'm very glad that I did because
this is as it turned out this proved to
be an important factor in my life I gave
her I received a certain
basic background in contemporary physics
so your initial bachelor's was math and
philosophy and then your Masters was
physics uh well actually I had a triple
Major Cornell I majored in physics
mathematics and philosophy
and I liked all three subjects very much
what aspect of physics did you do your
Masters in did you specialize it was in
quantum theory what aspect of quantum
theory well this was way back in
1948 to 1950 these are the two years I
spent at Cornell it was basic quantum
theory and incidentally we had very good
professors because this was immediately
after the war and a lot of top
professors from Europe came to the
United States and at Purdue at that time
uh
many of the senior professors were from
Germany
and in fact the head of the department
his name was Loch Horowitz he came from
Vienna my own Hometown you just watched
a clip from the theories of everything
channel for the full video in all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy